we get to the gig
and is packed
and they go now listen there's kids here
and there's students
and alum and the dean and all those
people here so
that's the worst yeah clean i get it no
worries
norm goes up i'm not even exaggerating
the first thing he says he goes out
against
and [ __ ] [ __ ] at me
first person even curse all right i went
oh [ __ ] he cursed he goes
so if you're gay
would you rather be the ass guy or the
dick guy
[Laughter]
spade makes me laugh mcdonald makes me
laugh i know everybody
you norm makes me laugh dude
hold on i'll do that thing about norm so
he did this thing one time
he gets up he go from one room into
another room right he stops at the
doorway and he's like
what is this what is like a
what is this he's like banging on the
door like just the doorway like
what is like a portal to like another
what is this and his ass he's literally
asking the people in the room right
what do what what do you call this thing
it's like a like a
portal to whatever how do you just go
through where am i
and he was just talking about a doorway
but it was so he makes anything funny
yeah
i remember it was me him he came
it was i think he was doing a show with
spade
in irvine and uh i went to go watch
and he came at it we went we went like
by the dumpster
afterwards and it was me him
i wonder what you're talking about
outside yeah that little outside area
where you park yeah yes
yeah and i don't know if it was
there was one other person there i
remember was there soon as uh he
said very are you stoned i would not man
i stopped because what
jesus christ [ __ ] guy from here babe
you can't [ __ ] stop getting i
[ __ ] you dying he was so angry till i
didn't want to get high
he was so pissed he was genuinely pissed
the [ __ ] is that who's the [ __ ]
brewing [ __ ] hey
jesus christ the [ __ ] his word are you
sure you again jesus cried through what
the [ __ ]
he was so you judge me now and no
no i just i stopped for a while man
that's
all i joked at all i did everything i
smoked as much as i
beat the [ __ ] out of marijuana yeah it's
hard i think you won one hit
i was crushing it i'm meeting up meeting
vaughn years before talking about
punching elephants in the nuts
been there done that i did it yeah dude
he
uh one time i had to open up for him and
this is at a casino we're doing like a
casino gig
in shawnee oklahoma and
cherokee creek casino i think and it
could have i don't know this cool lady
that i think maybe try to make love to
somebody but
she also helped us get the gig and um
norm was [ __ ] up i think that when he
went on he went on after me like i don't
think he
i don't even think for the first seven
minutes i don't even think he said
anything right but the crazy
part was the next day um
we were at there was like a we had to
play cards too the next day you'd like
be there for the weekend you know
so we'd go to the card tables and norm's
like
a lot of a lot of good [ __ ] in here
and i don't know him really well so i'm
thinking i'm looking around this room
bro there is
zero attractive women right they're zero
attractive men okay
so it's not even if you wanted something
scene there's nothing yeah it's a casino
and it's a it's a
gambling game it's poker yeah five card
poker you know so
and i'm just thinking well i guess i
just agree with him you know he's
getting older and you know maybe he has
a different perception of what's
attractive
i'm like yeah man there's sure easy goes
[ __ ] no there isn't like he had played
me you know like
he's like this is the ugliest batch of
people i've ever seen
i was just talking about him the other
day now i was there
for one of the greatest norm moments in
comedy history
i think he he was kinked he was kicked
out of nebraska
that sounds realistic um and i you can
maybe look it up later
versus norma mcdonald was kicked out of
state by the governor
and he went on he went on letterman
to talk about it uh and i want to say it
was like 1996
because i just finished my first year at
snl it was 95 so it was the summer of 96
and i remember going on tour there you
go you saw it go down
yeah kicked out of iowa that's me
talking about it okay
uh but anyway should we look on a video
or should we no no don't look at that i
want to see the real there has to be a
headline
how nor mcdonald got kicked out of iowa
yes okay gazette
there you go
okay all right so
many were disgusted some were delighted
so he's supposed now you understand
something okay
he his first time me touring with a star
okay we go to the airport and people
like oh my god you're norm mcdonald
wow this is everywhere we went oh my god
you're norm mcdonald
we show up at the university he's like
yeah i gotta go
golfing with the [ __ ] governor they
made me a [ __ ]
golf [ __ ] governor yeah yeah what did
that game were yeah
right so i'm like he's he's with a
governor
this is huge who gets to say that
so i'm i'm it's me daryl hammond and him
and you you all both you guys went
we're all we're on the gig okay okay
we're going out he's telling us
yes and so uh we get to the gig
and is packed
and they go now listen there's kids here
and they're students and alum
and the dean and all these people here
so that's the worst
they're like yeah clean i get it no
worries i go we're in sunny lagos that's
why we got you guys because you're used
to live tv
pull up so daryl goes up first does his
20 minutes
does impressions does his comedy
hilarious um i go up
do my 20 feel great crush it
norm goes up i'm not even exaggerating
the first thing he says he goes out he
goes
look it's like i'm preparing i'm like
this is gonna launch my crew are you
kidding me
this is gonna be huge i'm gonna be off
he goes ah
[ __ ] where the [ __ ] at me the first
person even curse
all right i went oh [ __ ] he cursed he
goes so
if you're gay
would you rather be the ass guy or the
dick guy
this is what he starts off with so
i go i go daryl you got to come see this
and he's going
and he won't stop he's there because if
you're depressed to them
people are grabbing their kids running
up the aisle they're
i mean i never saw a place clear out
looking like a fire alarm was going off
but the college students were staying
and they were
howling with laughter and he
one thing and then in the middle after
about 15 minutes he goes
jesus christ do you mean [ __ ]
airplane jokes
he went [ __ ] 7-11 joe said jesus
christ
[ __ ] out of here so the next day
in the paper usa today or the cassette
like norma mcdonald's out
wow governor wants him out of this state
get out of my state
but to witness that was i
i have so many more moments in my life
my first press conference with norm
was they prepped us into like you know
is he gonna speak
and it's just some it's live bbc
and he's a bigger star than you so you
have to sit there and kind of pay you
have to be it was him and spade right
next to him you have to be second fiddle
at the moment or were we
yeah man i just got i'm i'm the new kid
on the block we're all a new cast
it's all new cast except for spade tim
meadows
and nor mcdonald wow and we're like whoa
and even looking at norman spade i was
like
oh these guys are star like this is huge
yeah
i'm really looking up to them and uh
the press conference go and i dropped
the ball right out of the bat right out
of the bat
um they asked me the lor the head of nbc
who fought for me to be there
goes uh jim what was it like growing up
watching snl and now you're here you're
from new york and now a fellow new
yorker
i said i didn't watch snl growing up
well you can hear i was like oh
i saw i went oh that was
spade went so he said
i knew right away like oh man that was
really bad
that was a bad and so he goes i go well
i
i i wasn't allowed to because i was
young and
he goes what about when you were oh he's
trying to prep me he goes
surely when you got older and and you
were allowed to watch it
and i went i was out on saturday so i
wasn't watching tv
and and and norm's like
they're gonna like you you're gonna like
you yeah this guy is my guy
and he's smoking he's smoking and
and marcy klein was just going no put
out the singer i think i'm not done
this guy's gonna get fired so i think
i'm gonna get
fired because i saw lauren michael's
face he was pissed
so are you sitting there super nervous
at this point do i swear in my life from
my kid's lives i thought i was gonna get
fired
because i just basically said i don't
watch saturday live yeah and i never did
and yeah which is not not a good answer
the message
in front of the press yeah and i didn't
say it in a mean manner
but i could just tell the boss man was
like
uh so oh jesus lord so now i'm sitting
there thinking i'm gonna get fired
swear to god and i'm just like oh my god
even get i don't even make it the first
episode i'm going to let me go this is
what's going on my head
the has there has to be a video this
press conference
in the black market somewhere i i've
looked for it never found it
it's the 1995 press conference ca and
and so they asked norm they go norm
you tim meadows david spade
you've been here you you know the frat
house everyone knows
snl is a frat house what kind of what
kind of practical jokes you got lined up
for these new cast members
and i swear to you i went
i'm not even going to be part of the the
frat house or the practical jokes
and norm goes
he first always annoyed he goes
practical jokes
is that what you asked what kind of
practical jokes uh
first we were thinking about anal rape
you know like hey hey
yeah take your pain we're gonna italy
rape you
welcome to saturday live we're going oh
[ __ ]
he's gonna get fired too you can't say
you know rape you're from the president
he said anal rape just suddenly you're
like i'm back in there i'm in it
i'm good i'm good and i went up to him
after i went
no he's like dana again you know he has
a [ __ ] bro
you know he's [ __ ] these guys and i
realized he would pitch
at the pitch meeting he just didn't care
he didn't care
and i learned so much from him just
clearly he saw a lot and he's been there
forever like he would
i remember he gave he got he gathered
the new cast up he's a geek
sporting guys yeah don't
write me any of your gay sketches
[Laughter]
[Music]
right now and i do a sketch it's getting
on but don't put me in your gay little
sketches
[Laughter]
i swear to god man i also traumatized
him we were
we would play football in the hallway
because he was very competitive
he's always betting and it was a very
tiny hallway maybe as wide as this
maybe and uh he's like come on baby
thank you we're playing
three in the morning oh [ __ ] come on
ben [ __ ] playing football meet you
colin quinn
[ __ ] uh justin justin you [ __ ]
[ __ ] the phone calls no one's calling
three in the morning
get getting a [ __ ] ball let's go so
he would cheat would piss me off because
i'm competitive
and i'll never forget he keeps cheating
and cheating and
now i'm pissed how's he cheating it's
like a hallway it's like a hospital
hallway
but he [ __ ] cheat he's a cheater yeah
right so
oh yeah he has a cheater i had boots on
so i had i had work boots on yeah yeah
because yeah you use those to write in
yeah so is he running [ __ ] work boots
on stone oh the ink's heavy yeah yeah
so now he he
he cheat i caught the ball and then he
he grabbed it and pulled it from me he's
like hey fumbled
and he starts running the other way i'll
never forget i [ __ ]
kicked him as he's running in his in his
calf on
wow and he goes
jesus christ bro why did you [ __ ]
kick me in my [ __ ] calf
i said you're just cheating say you
[ __ ] kick me ah
jesus christ and all he did all week
he like [ __ ] really [ __ ] kicked me
in my calf
because i took the [ __ ] ball jesus
christ brewer
and spade just in the distance like
yeah so those in a moment
i absolutely i i loved more that stuff
you know all of it was worth it all of
it was worth it one needy but it was all
worth it
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one